-Obviously, I have to bring up
the fact that Donald Trump
attacked a city
that is in your state,
and he referred to Baltimore
as rodent-infested.
Your initial statement said,
you know,
that we're tired of attack
between politicians.
It didn't quite seem fair to m
to describe that as attack
between politicians.
Elijah Cummings doing his jo
on the Oversight Committee
and Donald Trump sort of makin
an ad hominem attack.
-Well, so, on Friday,
I gave a national address --
live national television -
to the National Governors
Association,
talking about,
that we have to do something
about the angry rhetoric
and the divisiveness
and all the attacks
and this politics
that's infecting America
and that's making it impossibl
for us to get anything don
in Washington.
14 hours later, we had
another perfect example
of exactly
what I was talking about.
And I said,
"The last thing I need to do
is jump in there
and have more angry reaction
to the angry reaction,
back and forth."
There were plenty of peopl
in America
that were tweeting
back and forth.
I just said, "Let's just
stop all the tweeting,
and let's focus on,
how are we going to solve
some of these problems
by working together?"
That's what America wants.
-I agree. I do agree.
There is that --
And, again, I don't want to sa
that politics wasn't divisiv
before Donald Trump.
Certainly, you would know that
better than me.
You come from --
Your family comes from politics,
so you know
the long history of it.
Your father was the first
Republican Congressman
to call for the impeachmen
of Richard Nixon.
-That's right.
-So you -- I think
you understand the history
of divisiveness.
It does seems like every time we
say these attacks have to stop
when we're talking about
something that's so specific
to what Donald Trump did,
it is spreading out the blam
in a way that's not quite fair
-Well, so, I said the comments
the tweet was outrageous
and unacceptable
and inappropriate.
That's a pretty strong comment
But I didn't jump in and
start jumping into the fra
and getting into the mud
with everybody else.
But look. I was elected four
years ago. I just got reelected.
In my inaugural address
in January of 2015,
I talked about
trying to move away
from the extremes
of either party
and to try to do something about
the broken politics in America
It's what I've been focused on
for four years.
It's why, as you pointed out
I'm one of the most popula
governors in America.
Not because I'm just
such a great, fun guy,
but because we're doing what
I think most people want,
and they just --
Regardless of whether
they're Republican or Democrat
they want all this nonsens
to stop,
and they want us to just
sit down and figure out a wa
to come up with bipartisan
common-sense solutions
to the serious problems
that are out there.
-I think because of that
and because of the things
you were saying about yourself
there was some talk about,
would you maybe
run against Donald Trump
in the primary.
You've decided against that,
and you've said that basically
it does right now seem lik
a party that is obviously
very satisfied with him.
Do you think that this
is a permanent situation
where the Republican Party
is the party of Donald Trump
or do you see a future
where that is not the case
-Well, it's definitely not
going to be the case forever
It's either
going to be next year
or four years after that, right?
It's not always going to b
the party of Donald Trump.
And there were a lot of people
that were approaching me
because I'm a different
kind of Republican
that's been talking out
in different ways.
But it didn't make any sense
I mean, look, there was --
I think there's a majority
of people in America
who agree with some of
the things I'm talking about
But they don't know
who the heck I am, number one.
Number two,
the Republican primary --
-I think you're as famous
as Donald Trump.
You're selling yourself short.
Look at this guy right here.
You remember him.
-Look at these moves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, you know,
in a Republican primary,
those voters seem to be stil
pretty stuck on Donald Trump
But there are an awful lot o
people in the middle in Americ
that would like to see us
go in a different direction.
-Well, keep up the good work
on climate change.
I'm really glad.
And try to convince
all the other governors
that you're right on that.
And thanks for making the time
for us. Really appreciate it
-Thank you, Seth.
-Governor Larry Hogan.